a serenade for the scientists on a stage
overlooking Lake Constance moments like
these make it easier for the Nobel Prize
winners and young researchers here to
get to know each other
physicist Gabriela Bartoli most comes
from Brazil she is currently working at
the Vienna Center for quantum science
and technology somehow an honor and also
privileged to see how how this world is
how the scientific academic high ranked
world is especially being from Brazil
this is an enormous privilege to have
access to this world for five days that
world is holding lectures and seminars
in lindau Nobel Prize winners talk about
their experiences as researchers and how
their lives changed post prize for many
of the young scientists a Nobel Prize is
the ultimate goal but at this year's
meeting another topic is on most
people's minds Britain's decision to
leave the European Union so this would
be a financial problem for the
universities because they'll they might
possibly depending on negotiations miss
out on access to the European science
fun
which would be a problem with many of my
colleagues young people are the only
ones worried about the brexit science is
an international endeavor and anything
that impedes the kind of interactions
between scientists that who may be from
different countries anything that
impedes that interaction is gonna slow
down the progress of science but the
main focus of the meeting is still on
physics this year's theme Gabriele
Alamos talks about her work ever since
mega concerns like Google have set their
sights on quantum computing billions
have been pouring into research on
quantum physics but as the only woman on
the panel Lemos has another message as
well this whole panel will be more
diverse in origin and gender I think we
are transitioning you see in the in the
room there were many people from
different places in different colors and
different gender and I think this is
really exciting the young scientists get
a chance to dine with their idols
exchanged between young and established
researchers is the whole point of the
lindau meeting at a gala dinner the
newcomers can ask the old hands
questions even if they aren't sitting
right next to a laureate Gabriella
lame-o's doesn't let that spoil her
evening
she has more luck the next day enjoying
FaceTime with one of her role models
what she wants to know from physicist
William Phillips is how to manage a
career and a family at the same time the
young people are the future of science
if we expect to make progress to learn
the about the incredible mysteries that
we're facing today then it's gonna be
these young people that do that and so
for me anything that I can do to to help
them along is great on her way to the
next event on the program lame-o's
enjoys getting to know so many other
young scientists from around the globe
science is not just the discovery of a
world that's there but it's a different
it's a way that we perceive our world
and if we have different looks different
people coming from different places they
will look at the world differently and
more creative models can arise by
meeting with Nobel Prize winners on lake
constance has been an annual event for
66 years now next year the focus turns
to chemistry